The joe rogan experience.
Just too many bongs out there.
Right.
People still rock the bond though.
Kind of respect that.
You know,
it's like driving a manual car.
I never was a Bongha.
It's too heavy,
man.
I got shit to do,
I can't,
oh,
the hitch just peeled down or the DAB
thing,
the,
I got friends in Colorado,
California now.
First time I ever did with Shit.
This is pretty embarrassing story,
but my,
uh,
my buddy,
you know,
they were all like California,
Colorado guys.
They roll pretty hard.
I'm not really a heavy smoker man,
to be honest on the road.
It keeps me occupied from time to time.
But if I'm writing maybe,
but at home,
you know,
it was no needs.
So it,
the first time I did that shit,
I didn't know what it was.
You know,
I just pulled it like it was a big old
bong rip and they're like,
everybody's face was like,
oh,
you know,
it was like,
I need,
you instantly know you just did
something you shouldn't have.
Oh.
And uh,
I was like,
Oh fuck man.
So I sat down and looked at a couple of
minutes.
I just started getting really cold and
clammy and I was like,
Yep,
I'm going to Puke.
So I went over and was like,
I'm fucked this guy.
So puke right in the sink.
And I was like,
dude,
I gotta go home.
I feel like dog shit now.
And I'm pretty sure I'm dying.
So I had,
we lived in this apartment and I was
like went out the door and turned the
corner to go down the hallway to mind.
And it was full on vertigo like the
hall.
Every time I took a step,
the hall we got twice as long.
That was like,
this is fucked up.
My wife was out of the country on work
at the time and I was like,
I remember I was sitting down in the
hallway just like trying to get my shit
together,
man.
Cause I thought I was having a fucking
heart attack.
It's just like sweating.
And I remember this voice saying,
get up you stupid junkie.
Fuck before somebody comes out here and
sees you.
You know,
sitting in the hallway like a dumb ass.
And I managed to like pop out of it and
as soon as I got back to my place and
sit down in the couch,
everything was fine,
but it was just so initial and the rush,
I was just like,
I don't,
nobody needs to be that stone.
You know that fast.
I'm sorry.
Uh,
yeah,
we worked on talking about joey getting
in trouble though.
He just,
uh,
just texted me about it.
How's Joey get in trouble with let the
MMA community MMA outlets,
they have nothing to do.
Well,
here's the thing though.
I see where they're coming from.
They're,
they're journalists.
If someone says something that fucking
outrageous about what mackenzie durans
dairy air must,
uh,
he said,
I think your ass smells great right
there.
Something like something along those
lines.
You're talking about the comic Uncle
Joey said this?
Yes,
the Commodore Google Joey.
But I get it.
I get where they would and then vinny
magallanes backed him up.
Yeah,
I get it packed up joey.
I backed up.
Joe,
he says something like,
and tasty to,
yikes.
Yikes.
I get it.
I don't get it.
That's a Joey Diaz,
the great comic who's commenting on a
hot girl in the UFC.
He is not a writer.
He's not a journalist.
These riders have nothing to do.
So they're like,
how can we get hits?
Let's talk about Joey,
right.
Cause no one's reading any of our shit.
I agree with you in somewhat,
but he definitely did do it.
Like it ain't a bat.
Here's my thing.
They could say whatever they want about
what he said,
but if he was your friend and he texted
you that you would do what I did cause
I'll show you.
He fucking texted me that before.
Tweet.
Of course.
I love the joey texts now.
Joey never would text message.
Oh,
I hope he doesn't keep your ideas as a
full on texting me.
He still calls though last week.
Most of the time he calls.
But um,
he texted me this.
Uh,
yeah,
it's Julie Diaz.
Manzi
sorry folks.
I wish I could let you in.
You can go and Google what he said.
I'll try and be respectful.
It's Joey Diaz.
He can say whatever he wants.
He doesn't work for the UFC.
He's not.
I'm glad he does.
I'm glad he does think like that.
How do you know?
Send me texts like that.
But if I was a news website and it was
going to report out to,
first of all,
you want to play.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's what they want,
but also anybody who reads that,
I really,
you're either going to be like me or
you're like,
you're going to start laughing or you're
going to get really upset,
really upset,
and you're not a [inaudible] fan anyway.
It doesn't matter.
It's 95% of that is dudes read and I'm
like,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
The 5% of like,
what the hell?
What are we doing?
How could you report this?
Yeah.
I think that's a good number.
95 95 that's hilarious.
I was wondering the same thing.
Some women will get upset though,
and rightly so.
If I had,
just to imagine if you were a dude and
there was some big Ole giant Alexander
Corel and looking dude who wanted to
fuck you and he was always making jokes
about what your butthole must smell
like.
Just stop.
Just stop and think of what that would
feel like.
That wouldn't be a good time.
If you're Mckenzie,
if you're anybody that someone is saying
those things about right.
I would just be,
and just trying to be open mind cause
you're not going off
a little bit.
Turn social justice.
I'm fucking account.
I came out.
It's not possible,
but what I'm saying is if you look at it
from the position of the person,
the person who's buttholes in question,
that would be an uncomfortable position
to in right.
Bunch of people talking about what your
butthole smelled like.
We just try to make a living on TV.
I just tried to make a living.
Just tried to trick a girl.
You know what that it's,
it's also Joey Dheas being
complimentary.
Yeah.
It'd be one thing if she was not an
attractive female shut like that.
She's obviously very attractive,
which is what makes us funny.
I agree 100%.
There's definitely people that are bored
with though like enough.
Well they Hollywood's over.
I think Hollywood tends to be,
what bothers me about Hollywood is their
virtual virtue signaling.
Like they're going to set an example.
You fucking guys like you want to be
liked.
Okay.
And you're as fickle as it gets.
They were the same people that were
standing up and clapping for Roman
Polanski.
I'm sorry man.
Well some of them were,
some of them were really saying some
ridiculous shit.
I mean guys,
it's a long time ago and he's drugged
and sodomized.
A 13 year old,
I think he was like more than one too.
Yeah.
So guess what?
I can't have that guy.
You're not kidding.
They wanted to sign a petition to bring
them back in the country.
I can't forgive that.
No stay in France.
Well they want to bring it back to the
country to arrest them and they're
really trying hard to do that.
And there's people that resist that.
I think he's an amazing artist and you
know,
artists are just be consistent though,
you know you can system.
That's where I draw the line.
You can't drug kids fucking with the HR
Argento who was one of the,
one of the people that came out against
Harvey Weinstein,
she had been raped by him apparently.
And then she had a sexual relationship
with for 10 years afterwards,
which by the way,
people are like Ah,
that I actually forgive that because
people go back to the trauma,
right?
They want to relive it on their own
terms.
But she signed the petition to for,
for Roman Polanski to,
you know,
to be freed when he was put under arrest
and I believe it was Switzerland.
And now that's not consistent.
I'm sorry man.
I'm sorry.
But if that guy is just as bad as yeah,
you can see the petition online.
What was her perspective?
She was somebody who thought Roman
Polanski should not be prosecuted for
something that happened a long time ago.
She signed that petition.
I would never sign that petition.
So there's a lot of disconnect.
So I have a big problem with that sort
of disconnect.
That's a problem.
I don't know this woman,
I don't know her.
Um,
I believe her.
I believe what she says about Harvey
Weinstein.
Uh,
and again,
I,
you know,
people are like,
well she went back to the scene of the
crime.
That's very common,
but don't sign a petition and then now
be this leading voice in this whole,
you know,
anti harassment.
It's like,
I think it's very inconsistent.
I think you have to pay,
you have to at least answer to that.
Did she comment on,
she signed,
there was a mia culpa there,
but it's very inconsistent in it and
there's a lot of that up.
So No,
a bunch of my s team members are going
to shoot me in the face for talking
about this because in the face,
yeah,
literally in the face.
Because one thing that was an ongoing
thing when I was on the u s team,
we,
there was this thing that went on about
how long we could go at a tournament
before we talked about this particular
person.
So during my time on the teams,
we actually had a person that was,
um,
she claimed to have a medical disorder
or she didn't actually claim to have it,
but supposedly it happens,
but she claimed have a disorder where
she had attachment to items.
This girl that was on my team actually
ended up marrying the Eiffel Tower.
Are you serious?
I'm not kidding.
She and she had an attachment to
a loving,
she actually filed some claims against,
supposedly filed some claims against a
bow company that this boat company
actually had a rubber laminate on the
limbs of the bow and
is Mary's I fuck hour has that her?
Wow.
She Man Harris is famous monument.
I wrote a many buses with you,
Roy with her.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Cool.
She's a former soldier who lives in San
Francisco.
She has been in love with the objects
before.
Their first infatuation was with lance,
a bow that helped her become a world
class.
Our chair,
she is fond of the Berlin Wall and she
claims to have a physical relationship
with a piece of fence.
She keeps in her bedroom and the fuck.
What I doing?
What do we do with people?
We can't,
we can't do this.
We've gotten too crazy.
We got to pull back.
Here's the thing,
Mary,
a fucking bridge.
Just pitch.
Married a bridge.
She married a Brooklyn.
She's married the Eiffel Tower.
This bitch is marrying a bridge though.
Just kissing,
kissing bridges,
parts of being in love with a public
object.
But what the fuck does she just say?
You love the public object.
The crank that up.
I want to hear this crazy lady.
I feel very,
very blessed to have a piece of my sweet
Golden Gate Bridge.
Oh,
Jesus stopped.
I give up.
I'm out
my new there,
as long as I could love with the bridge.
Okay.